and you never sleep and i think
like if women were valued in the
feminine like
typical female roles then maybe like
life would be better because i would
love to be a housewife
it feels like it's not even a it's not
even an option anymore
like what the first guy could you have
been um
yeah
no not no because like we'd like i don't
know i don't know how much money he's
because
but like i wouldn't have been able to be
just a whole like a housewife like
economically that's just not viable
anymore unless you're dating like
millionaires billionaires well you know
what's crazy my friends i have a really
good friend that's a housewife and she
she went like she was trending on
twitter for just saying that she was a
housewife and she served her she loves
her husband she serves him he's the boss
and like it's crazy to me that that so
much backlash
are so foreign
um so important well that's where it
goes back to statistics about a nuclear
family right that i read in the
beginning of the show because having
that nuclear family is essential for
societies to function um i i think the
society is a little bit dis well a lot
dysfunctional because of the lack of
nuclear family structure yeah and you
know i would also argue that it is
possible
as a woman i guess to find a guy who's
able to look after you and your kids so
you don't have to work but the reality
is you need to be strategic about how
you're going to actually get that guy to
commit to you you need to provide value
in certain ways and a lot of women like
and i'm not saying this is good or bad
it's just they need to understand what
the consequences of this belief is going
to be right you need to understand if
you believe that a guy who has a lot of
options should just choose you why
because you're you then
the result of that is not going to be
you know amicable for you right that's
the reality so you need to realize that
or women need to realize if you're going
to keep a guy who has a lot of options
you need to provide a lot of tangible
value apart from just whatever you can
do in
a sexual domain well but also
also
in reverse to that
if a man wants a woman of a caliber or a
certain caliber he has to provide 100 so
many different things as in like wealth
he has to be
the type of man she would admire look up
to in any way shape or form he has to
behave in a certain manner for her to
even like somewhat respect him or feel
comfortable
just
essentially
relinquishing
certain powers of course i mean sorry
yeah well everything a woman does in a
relationship is for her happiness
everything a mandan is does in a
relationship is for a woman's happiness
generally
a woman does things in a relationship so
she can be happy
right and then the man
does things in a relationship so she can
be happy right happy wife happy life
right so we get that term happy wife
happy life and so what happens is all of
this attention is just thrown upon the
woman it's all about her happiness all
about her happiness all about you keep
an open happy and a man goes out
generally he goes out to work
brings home the bacon yeah and he's got
to protect this whole structure he's got
to protect her happiness
make sure she's happy and then keep her
happy all the while negating his own
generally he negates his own happiness
to keep the woman happy
do you get what i'm saying wouldn't you
agree then that the issue is more that
we should fulfill our own happiness
instead of relying on our partners to
fulfill that for us and that will shift
the dynamic of being like having that
dependence and so if a woman has that
independent energy she's able to look
after herself she's able to attract a
man who can look after himself and
together they can probably look after a
child because they're not searching for
their happiness in each other so
wouldn't you say that's more the issue i
think yeah i think people should
fulfill themselves within whatever
happiness whatever makes them happy yeah
i don't think life's about happiness
it's about fulfillment and i think and i
think women over a certain age are not
fulfilled if they don't have a husband
and a family like what are you going to
do at 60 by yourself you have a job you
have a job that could fire you tomorrow
do you think that's because we've been
taught that that's what fulfills us
especially in terms of that nuclear
family no no no no no so to answer your
question to answer your question no i
think it's biology i think you can't
undo biology but i think even biology to
an extent is taught because it's evolved
it's evolved from what we practice over
and over and over again right so that's
still generational to me that's still
taught that goes back that dynamic goes
back years but it doesn't mean
necessarily that it's the most healthy
dynamic yeah
you know social constructs change every
what a couple hundred years biology is
like well scientists estimate 300 000
years that human beings have been like
300 000 years of evolutionary biology
that's not really a that's a very
formidable opponent that you don't
really want to be going against it's
less like in the past than that i mean
the roles the roles of kind of like more
in like sophisticated society we live in
this society where that role is a bit
more structured it's a bit more defined
than it was previously where the woman
was um the nurturer of the forager you
know she had an active role in society
she was just as important as the man she
was seen as an equal because they had
equal roles instead of the man being
this power when sorry sorry
when um
i couldn't give you a specific taco
because i think before like
sophisticated societies start developing
even like medieval stages
i'm saying i don't think it was ever
equal because men always had to protect
women but that doesn't mean that the
woman's
position is less valued it's valued it's
it's valuable in a different i'm saying
they did different things oh exactly but
i'm just i i like no one's talking about
what's more valuable or what's less
right but both are valuable yeah yeah
yeah
yeah nobody's saying women like what
they do isn't valuable what we're saying
is men and women are different and you
can't you can't undo biology and i don't
know why you would want to change
something that's worked for thousands
and thousands of years so it's like
don't you think it's a bit arrogant to
come in and don't you think it's a bit
arrogant to come in and say you know
better than like thousands of years of
people i think it's more the rigidity
i'm talking about the rigidity of the
roles that we are expected to be in a
certain way
with flexibility
so so to me like i i've always been told
i can do anything and i could be like i
could start a business i could do what i
want i've never been pushed into roles
and if anything i've seen more backlash
for women that go into traditional roles
than women that act more modern so i
don't think society's really pushing
women to be traditional anymore i know
and that's i definitely agree with that
because it is pushing women to be more
professional because
in capitalism where your value comes
from
not by everyone but
people see you
in a higher status if you earn more
money you earn no money looking after
children unless you're a nanny and when
you look at the salary of a nani
compared to a banker you know
it's not it's and that's why women feel
like they need to go off and like
succeed and become a valuable member of
society because i don't feel like having
a baby is enough to be valued which is
so depressing but why does it shouldn't
it shouldn't it only matter if your
husband values you who cares what
society thinks
everyone that's like humans care what
other humans think like that's like how
to stay in in a society to not get
kicked out of one to die or you're right
there you can actually care what other
people think and you want to make sure
that every year but you need to pick the
people whose opinions you actually value
right you can't just value everyone's
opinions because at the end of the day
people
people's lives their lifestyle is a
reflection of the opinions that they
have so if you don't want this person's
lifestyle in future then you really
shouldn't be internalizing their
opinions because you will be doing
yourself a massive decision very
difficult there's a certain level of
consciousness that requires that as well
which is like an incredibly privileged
space to be in because if you are living
in survival mode effectively which a lot
of people are then you don't have the
conscious awareness to make those
decisions you're going to keep falling
into those survival patterns because you
can't physically step out of that you
don't have the choice to and because of
different systemic pressures so many
different factors contributing to that
i just have no idea what you just said i
would argue for personally
i mean i would argue from personal
experience that's incorrect like when i
left home when i was 17 and it was all
about survival i really couldn't care
less what anyone thought about me the
only people whose opinions i cared about
were people who had the lifestyle i
wanted to have in the future and and
that was it like if you don't have the
lifestyle i want in three to five years
or you know the the results you have in
this particular field of discussion
isn't desirable to me then i have no
choice but to disregard your opinion
because i'll be doing myself a massive
disservice ultimately but it's such a
privilege to have um no it's not it's a
privilege to know people that you want
to be like not everyone is in a in like
a community where they can look up to
someone who is a positive influence of
what you want to be
and like i get when you're an adult
you've got a choice where you live but
at the end when you're growing up like
you only know what you know yeah but i
became that influence for myself
do you think it's a privilege to be born
in 2022 where you're richer than most
people even the richest people were in
all of human history so even like poor
people today are richer than people were
in most of history you never know
because you don't know what it's going
to be like in 20 years no no but we know
but we know what's going on the last
like four thousand yeah yeah so so you
could say being born in 2022 is much
better than being bored during the
plague yeah yeah yeah you could just go
so
so so it's all about perspective right
because like if anything everybody's
privileged in 2022. but i think one of
the reasons why people are the most
depressed in in these days and times
because we take the most antidepressants
we're the most anxious we're the most
depressed in the west is because we have
put we have put expectations upon
ourselves
right which are basically unrealistic
and so we get upset and you know we get
depressed by the fact that we can't
actually reach those expectations
whereas
you know if you go back
to the 60s 50s
40s people were happier
because people talk about especially
when it comes to women right people talk
about oh women had to they never had any
rights and they had to you know ask men
for everything they were happier they
want less antidepressants they were less
anxious
they were less there was less anxiety
there were there was less mental
illnesses in in in the dsm yes but
that's because
feminine mental illness was defined as
hysteria and women were sent to like get
you know electro therapy because they
were emotional and that's any kind of
mental illness was defined as that it's
not because it wasn't present it's
because we didn't have the words to
define it
instances of that a lot so you to use it
as the general rule
is a misnomer there were a lot more than
instances of it that was the majority of
women who expressed any sort of
emotionality beyond the point of what
was expected
were defined as having hysteria and they
were required or a witch burned at the
stake for literally being melancholy
you're going back to like 17 like no